d'abord un petit mot sur votre rôle vous
jouez qui alors je joue le rôle de
léonore une
une épouse une mère qui est un peu la
gardienne du temple puisque c'est elle
qui entretient la légende de ce grand
homme qu'est carole franck mort il ya
peut-être dix ou vingt ans et voilà elle
elle a fondé une espèce de fait une
feinte une espèce de fondation à son nom
elle organise des soirées ensemble en sa
mémoire et elle voudrait elle présente
son fils pour la première fois à la
bonne société suppose que c'est la bonne
société viennoise puisque son fils veut
être auteur également comme son père
alors on imagine bien le poids qui pèse
sur les épaules de ce jeune homme qu'est
ce qui vous plaît dans cet univers de ce
bug
alors moi j'aime beaucoup le les romans
les
les biographies les nouvelles de stefan
zweig là on est vraiment dans son
théâtre qui est vraiment une toute
petite part de son oeuvre et qui
d'ailleurs lui ressemble sans lui
ressembler c'est à dire que c'est une
pièce qui traite des liens familiaux
d'une crise dans une famille da secret
alors ça c'est pas étranger à son oeuvre
mais c'est une pièce qui se termine
plutôt bien ce qui est assez étrange
pour une oeuvre de stefan zweig et ce
qui me plaît c'est ce et c'est là la
force des rôles et la force de
l'histoire en fait on y parle de secret
d'identité
oui et puis pour ce qui me concerne
c'est une femme qui va qui va quand même
terriblement évolué elle a passé du
stade de vestale au stade de femmes au
bord de la crise de nerfs et femmes dans
la crise de nerfs et retournements de
situation complet la fin je peux pas en
dire trop non plus cela dit c'est pas
fait pour vous déplaire puisque vous dit
j'adore j'adore jouer les sorcières oui
oui alors c'est une femme qui peut
paraître comme ça très très antipathique
très autoritaire très présentes hier et
qui règne un peu sur cette maison et qui
met une comme une espèce de chape de
plomb sur ce secret et cette maison et
cette famille et en même temps on va
s'apercevoir que comme tout un chacun
est capable de craquer et de révéler une
autre facette d'elle même alors on vous
connaît chanteuse bien sûr est ce vrai
j'ai lu je crois dans paris match
j'ai toujours voulu être comédienne ah
oui moi j'ai commencé avec ça c'est à
dire de 18 à 20 ans j'ai fait le théâtre
j'ai fait des études de théâtre avant
même de faire des études de chant donc
oui je voulais devenir comédienne
mais comme j'avais une voix je me suis
dit que le plus court chemin pour moi
est le plus sûr chemin pour être sûr
d'aller sur scène interpréter le
personnage je serais probablement grâce
au chant et je ne suis pas trompé
puisque j'ai fait ce métier pendant 23
ans
pendant trente ans j'ai chanté de
manière classique
et puis il ya quelques années j'ai
décidé vraiment de tourner la page de
l'opéra et de faire enfin ce que je
voulais faire
au début c'est à dire jouer sans chanter
c'est fou d'attendre 50 ans non enfin
wydad ans l'âge de 50 ans voulait dire
oui oui j'ai attendu trente ans fait
mais j'ai beaucoup de patience et quand
vous êtes sur scène comment vous êtes
comment vous vous sentez moi je me sens
chez moi au théâtre plus son corps qu'à
l'opéra alors que c'est un métier
extrêmement délicate est très différent
de celui de chanteur parce que là on est
beaucoup plus dans les mots on est
beaucoup plus dans dans les sentiments
dans les émotions et ses émotions qui
changent d'une phrase à l'autre en fait
alors que en chant on peut développer
exactement le même sentiment ou la même
motion pendant un quart d'heure on n'est
pas du tout dans la même temporalité et
là-haut au théâtre c'est nous qui sommes
maîtres du temps c'est pas la musique
alors qu'à l'opéra évidemment c'est la
musique dictats le temps cela dit au
fond de vous vous avez toujours été
comédienne
ah oui moi j'ai toujours dit que j'étais
une comédienne qui chantent mais
maintenant je suis une comédienne qui
parle ça se passe bien les dernières
répétitions vous êtes prête là on est à
deux heures on on est prêt ou à lyon
il est évident que c'est un spectacle
qui va qui va évoluer qui va mûrir et
qui va nourrir aussi énormément mais on
a bien travaillé et je crois qu'on a
très envie de le jouer surtout dans la
petite question concernant christophe
votre metteur en scène christophe lidon
qu'est ce que vous diriez de lui moi je
dirais que c'est quelqu'un qui sait voir
à travers des gens ça c'est une grande
qualité pour un metteur en scène parce
qu'ils n'opèrent ça jour et ils nous
poussent aussi dans nos retranchements
ça c'est beau aussi d'être à la fois
porter et porter plus loin que ce qu'on
aurait cru qu'on pouvait faire et il
nous engage à nous donner toujours plus
et toujours mieux à nos collègues et à
nous mêmes et aux textes exigeants
exigeant très très très amoureux de ces
comédiens jaloux de ses comédiens de sa
famille et il a su aussi créé une
famille avec nos 5 quand ils vous avez
vu je crois que c'était dans la maison
de michel legrand
il vous a pris à part et mâcha l'allier
vous avez dit tout
est ce que vous avez dit oui tout de
suite ou quand c'est non c'est pas tout
à fait passé comme ça on s'est d'abord
rencontré et il s'est dit que comme
j'étais très distante mais un peu froide
comme ça ça irait très bien au
personnage de l'est nord est en fait
c'est drôle parce que moi je ne le vis
pas du tout comme ça je suis quelqu'un
d'assez timide et c'est sans doute pour
ça que je véhicule cette image peut-être
de froideur à certains égards mais donc
tant mieux si ça a pu l'inspirer pour me
donner ce rôle parce que c'est vraiment
très très très beau rôle